نحن في قسم غسيل الكلى وحده غسيل الكلى في
قاسم عموما وضع المستشفيات بسبب انقطاع
الكهرباء مره
وعودتها في مرات يتطلبا تزود هذه
المستشفيات
بالوقود الذي يسهل لها اعاده تشغيل
الماكينات التي تقوم بتوليد الطاقه
بالنسبه لها الامر الاخر المتعلق
بالامدادات الطبيه بالنسبه للمستشفيات
والموضوع غسيل الكلى وحدات غسيل الكلى
احتياجات خاصه قبل يعني تختلف عن
المستشفيات الاخرى مستشفيات الطوارئ وصفات
المتعلقه بالولاده والاطفال وما الى ذلك
ونستطيع ان نتعرف على المشاكل التي تواجه
هذه الاقسام من المستشفيات وحده غسيل
الكلى مع الدكتور عثمان موسى عثمان يعني
باعتبارك مشرف اللي
هذه الوحده ما هي المشاكل التي تواجه
المرضى الذين ياتون هنا لغسيل الكلى
وعليكم السلام واحده من المشاكل الهمه
المتواجهه المرضى
يستطيعوا يصلون لهذه المركز بسبب ارتكازات
بسبب التوقف
يعني عنده مشكله ماديه واي مريض بتاع غسيل
الكلى ماديا يعني وضعه مدني اول ما بدات
الاحداث كان المخزون الموجود داخل
قسم الكلى احمد قاسم يمكن اقول لك ما
حينتهي
اللعبه معدلين انا كنت بغسل 40 غسله خلال
اليوم الان بغسل 60 غسله وخلاص انا على
مشارف هذا المستشفى بالتحديد يعني تواصل
الليل بالنهار وهذا الطبيب الذي تحدثنا
معه قليل قبل قليل لم ينم الا ساعتين خلال
يوم امس واغلب الاطباء هنا كلهم يعملون
بجهد مضاعف هناك نقص في الكوادر ومنهم
متطوعين يعملون باستمرار في هذا المستشفى
وهم منذ اندلاعي هذه المواجهات وهذه
الازمه ما زالوا في المستشفى لم يخرجوا
منها وما زالوا يقدمون خدماتهم في اي وقت
وباي ساعه